hey what's up my name is samuel leeds
welcome to another winners on a
wednesday every single week
i interview people that have absolutely
killed in property that have benefited
from our training
this week's a little different i want to
introduce you to a guy called tony
tony's made millions of pounds in
property
he's made millions of pounds in business
he's 56 years old he's actually been a
mentor to me
he's done the training he's an
ambassador and uh you're going to learn
a lot from this interview so please do a
massive favor if you enjoy my videos
smash the like button also subscribe
drop a comment below and tony welcome to
winners on the wednesday how you feeling
great feel really good excited to be
here you know what tony i am so
i'd be pinching myself if i don't know
that we'd be working so closely together
because
and i have to have to give it to you
know you've trained me a lot as well
and i know it's being mutual you learn
about property for me
even though you've been in property
longer than i've been in and uh
it's just great to work with you and uh
thank you so much so
firstly why would you why did you agree
to come on winners on a wednesday
um i've been you know i've heard about
women as well as the last year and a
half and um i've always
uh been excited when people come on and
i'm excited to be here today
yeah and you've gone through the
training i have yeah but you've been in
property for a lot longer so i can't
take credit for all of your success in
fact you can take credit for some of my
success
um before we kind of talk about what's
happening now and our relationship and
exactly what's going on yeah why don't
you just tell me
you've made actually more money in
business than in property right
yeah business has always been my my
driving force and the businesses
as has allowed me to invest money in
property
but you were always one of those guys
that would make a fortune in business
and then you were just kind of like
dumping it into property but now you're
being a little bit more creative
yeah so now now i know what i know now
yeah
obviously it's things are a lot lot
different yeah before
the business of my vehicle the property
was more of a pleasure more of a fun
thing than something the thing that i
had to do
yeah or i should do and i did do it but
um i'm much more wise now it's so funny
though because i see it as the opposite
i i i think
i do business for fun and i do property
to get me rich
that's that's my mindset but with for
you it was always the other way around
what what um how did you make so much
money in business
in business i started um at a very young
age
and i i enjoyed working for myself
i enjoyed i understood the how to
leverage other people and other ways of
making money
through business and business came
natural to me um
and i was good at it i'm still am good
at it i still do i've run
businesses for over 30 years now um very
successful
uh my businesses have made over 100
million pounds of um
of turnover in those 30 years that's
incredible though
you must have you must have helped a lot
of people along the way
absolutely yeah making money i believe
is such a good thing because people
think you know 100 million
oh you must have screwed a lot of people
over but no people have been giving your
company the money because your company's
been adding value
not that as i employed over 100 people
uh
in my time has been in business yeah uh
people who have been with me for a long
long period of time
people who um you know got out got
partners
they bought houses uh they had children
all under my watch
yeah so that makes me feel really really
good and how we kind of connected
was that my business mentor who i've had
by the way
since i was 17 years old um is doug
dobbery
from executive training consultants
absolutely and you and doug were working
together
doing training and coaching and things
like that and um
you know i just saw the experience that
you'd had in business
how many people had employed how many
tens of millions
you turned over and i'm like i need to
get i need to get some of this
because you know i was making money as
in property as a property entrepreneur
buying houses renting them out but then
as i was growing and as i was hiring
staff
i needed more and more support on the
business front and you know you were
such a good
mentor um but then you were kind of
mentoring me but you were getting
all the property stuff absolutely right
and you were like oh you can do that and
oh you can do this
um and then we'll talk about what we're
doing now and how we're working together
but talk to me about some of the recent
property stuff you've got going on the
different
because you've made millions of pounds
in property okay but then
part of the way you've made money is
just by waiting for the properties to go
up in value right
absolutely yeah yeah so so so give me
some examples like tell me about your
first property that you bought what year
was it
so when i first came to england i grew
up in america and i first came to
england when i was
in 20 when i was 20 years old i bought a
property with the help my family
um and that's when house prices it was
uh circa 1983-84
uh where house price was just going up
and they were going up month
every month they were going up higher
and i so i made a lot of money in that
property
uh i sold it and then i paid back
the my family members who lent me the
money and i
took the profits and traveled around the
world for a couple of years that's
that's crazy because that's not that
different from what what i teach now
right
it's a bit of a joint venture you
brought them you raised the finance on
it how much did you make on that first
deal
i made about 40 grand okay and you
traveled the world with the money
travel the world with the money yeah you
didn't think to reinvest it
uh no not at that age i just yeah yeah
you just enjoyed it i guess especially
with your mindset of properties fun
right i made 40 grand in property i'll
i'll travel the world
okay um and then then what was your next
deal
so next year i came back to england and
i bought the
the next house i bought when the house
prices were were
probably at the top what year was i
didn't know that since 1987 88
right um and within within months of me
buying that house
house prices crashed we had a big crash
in this country
and um it went from where i bought it at
90 000 pounds
it went down to 55 000 pounds within the
space of six months
jeez and you know what though tony i'm
glad you said that
because people are so afraid that that
will happen oh is there going to be a
crash i'm scared to buy in case of the
crash but what they forget is
even if there's a crash if you hold on
to it
it doesn't matter because ultimately
it's going to bounce back up
so this property you bought for you
bought for for 90 000.
it dropped to 55. i did you kept it
right yeah at that stage a lot of people
were handing their keys in
you know uh handing back to morris
companies i didn't want to do that
they were freaking out they were freaked
out i bet you any money when it dropped
to 55 grand they were thinking
it's just gonna keep going low and lower
it's gonna be worth nothing yeah
but you were like no no no it will
bounce back and interest rates were
about 23 percent
oh geez see this is obviously i've
studied the history of economics and
property
but this is way before my time i bought
my first house
2000 no 2009 yeah beginning in 2009
so this is way before my time um so
you kept the property what happened to
that i mean let me ask you a question
over the next 10 years you kept it right
yeah what happened over the next 10
years i kept it out i kept it i rented
it out and i made money
so somebody else paid my mortgage but
not only they paid me more
it actually made me a profit yeah every
month which is great just suddenly
this like awakening like wow um
and eventually the house prices went up
as you said i sold it 10 years later at
180 000 pounds so i actually doubled my
money there we go
in 10 years but from a from a deficit of
40 000 pounds up to a profit of uh
people's biggest fear with property is
that the property is going to crash
or interest rates are going to rocket
you had both of those things happen but
you still made money through it how are
you making cash flow when the interest
rates were so high
um it's still still worked out yeah wow
nice it wasn't making a big profit but
it made profit it made yeah
interesting yeah so so then you know the
single letter right
so then you were just sort of like doing
your business and what was your you had
a printing business right
yeah how how are you making so many
millions
on a printing business it doesn't make
sense um
printing you know has suffered over the
of the
the least of the latest years but profit
you know
printing's always made money it's just
you had to become smarter and smarter
about the way you
where you where you ran in print company
so basically i started running my print
company 24 hours a day seven days a week
where other printers weren't doing it uh
printers would say or say well you can
have it two to three weeks
we'd say well when do you want it we can
do it when when you want it so
it was really customer focused yeah
business so i
the customer was always right the
customer led led my business so
by being that proactive in business it
made me money so you basically just
found out what people wanted and then
figured a way to give it to them
and then got rich off the back of it
yeah and then and then you're making
money doing that
but then you were using the profits
you're investing it into property
absolutely have you made millions in
property
well once again when i when i started
learning about how i can make money
through property and
you know without me owning it uh we
started
looking around me and my family sort of
going on holidays thinking
i'm the kind of person whenever we go on
holiday we think wouldn't it be lovely
to have a house here
yeah and what we did was we bought a
house there so
um but then i thought was there's no
point having a house
in a place where you know you you don't
see it
and so forth so you buy that house we
then rented it out
um uh sort of what we called holiday
lats back then before service
combination became a thing
holiday let's and any time we had voids
between
let's me and the family would go and
have a free holiday
nice so and and although that you had
the money to do that and that
when you came to the property investors
crash course just a few years ago
what did you think about your entire
property strategy like what happened
absolutely so i i sort of done some buy
refurbished
mints i would always buy a house i'd
refurbish it and it'd be a higher value
but i didn't really know any of the
other sort of strategies um and how
i mean for rent rent uh lease option
agreements things like that i just had
no idea about until i came to
uh start doing the courses yeah what
what was your experience with the first
property investors crash course
um it was just it was mind-blowing
eye-opening um i actually came there
as a coach to be an accountability coach
employed by you to
look after some of the academy members
yeah on accountability
but as i started going there and sort of
understanding what they were learning
yeah it was dawning on me that i
actually could learn a lot here
yeah and that's that's what i was going
to bring to because it was so beautiful
how it happened so basically
um you're obviously a coach business
person the cousin of doug dobbery as
well
yeah and um i just thought etc executive
training consultancy
they've trained me in business they have
kept me accountable
so when i was having people come into me
saying samuel i want to join your
academy i want to do further training
i want to i thought well actually if
people are joining the academy
i'm going to coach them i'm going to
train them i'm going to mentor them
but in order to give them the best
experience i thought if i can bring in
some of my mentors
if i can bring in some of my coaches so
my students have got the best of the
best of the best so that's why i reached
out to um
executive training consultancy um that
you were working with i was like
hey do you mind coming down coaching
some academy members but in order to
coach them
you've got to come to the crash course
to get an idea a bit a little bit about
property absolutely but i want you to
really teach them the business side
staff management business plans goal
setting
this kind of stuff so you obviously came
on and we employed you to do some
coaching with the students
and i remember you just saying to me
like dude this this property stuff like
i want in on this you know i want to be
i want to be a winners on a wednesday i
want to be doing
absolutely and we started doing deals
together yeah i mean we're doing a deal
right now together
mm-hmm what what
we were doing the one yeah we lost it
this is where i need to discipline my
disappointment um but but still
like okay it falls through but that's
again the the the
the human in me yeah will be like oh my
gosh a deal fell through and you'll
start crying about it but the
businessman in me which i've been taught
just goes
discipline you disappoint me move on to
the next deal um but anyway you've been
doing
more creative deals recently than should
we say absolutely so talk to me about
some of the
more recent deals so obviously i i
didn't even know what an hmo was before
i met you yeah
and now i'm actually buying um a 10 bed
hmo in lincoln
nice yeah what are the figures uh the
figures is it's buying it for
uh it's a buy refurbished finance i
should be able to pull most of my money
out
uh after i've done up the 10 bedrooms so
how much are you buying it for a bike
240
yeah and suit spend 60 on it okay so
you're talking about 300 all in 300 all
in
yeah and it should be valued at a
commercial valuation of 380 000 pounds
maybe 400 000 pounds depending on so
you're going to push the value up by
almost 100 grand
yeah and talk to me about why you chose
to go down the commercial valuation
route because that's that's uh
especially as a businessman there's
there's advantages right to
valuing it based on the commercial rent
talk a little bit about that well with a
10b hmo it has to go so it's almost you
know it has to be a commercial
sort of valuation on it because it is
really a business um
yeah and a business which which makes a
you know has a turnover and makes a
profit so
um by valuing on a commercial basis
rather than bricks and mortar
the the lenders will value at a much
higher uh rate because it is worth
more in business yeah so it's like
buying a business like me buying
um a local print company another print
company something so
it is a bonafide business and i think as
well you know
we always teach this and you know this
now you're one of our coaches
make money invest money yeah you need to
be able to do the two
you know make money maybe doing rent to
rent deal packaging
having a print business whatever make
your money here
and then invest it over here and um you
know you've also i know you've
started doing some of the creative make
money strategies as well kind of just
for fun
you've been helping some of the students
you picked up but did you pick up a
rental rent deal last year did i hear
you did a rent director yeah
what was that tell me about that
literally just before covert because i
think rent to rent was fascinating me i
thought
this is definitely a way of um you know
of using other people's money to make
yourself money
leveraging off of other people so i mean
if you you know investing in property
one
sooner or later you may run out of money
rent rent is a great strategy where you
could just keep on
increasing your cash flow kishore castle
so i was really really interested in
doing that
a couple of academy members uh were
struggling a little bit
they sort of asked me if um if they if i
wanted to go with them on site
um and i said yeah sure so we we went on
site over a weekend
um in february to look at some houses
we um saw some estate agents looked a
few
and we then actually made an offer and
got it agreed
to do a rent to rent in birmingham yeah
nice
people make such a song and dance about
finding deals like
i think the thing is when you come when
you come to property and you look at it
as a business
like you you look at it it's like oh you
can just do this and this and this and
this
but when you come to property and you've
got no business experience whatsoever
you know you pluck up the courage to
phone an estate agent and you
yeah and then you bring them up and you
pitch and then they go no thanks we're
not interested
and then you're like oh and you knocked
back and and you have to get over it and
you feel rejected whereas when you
when you're used to business it's just
you just pick up the phone you do it
you get rejected and you move on to the
next absolutely yeah um you know and i
think property investing
it is a business and people don't get
that
people think that oh i'll just you know
buy a house and rent it out and
you know i don't need to go on the
courses to learn how to do that and it's
like well no this
is a business um talk to me a little bit
about the power of training i mean
you're
you're you chose to be a coach i know
you've had coaching you've had mentors
um talk a little about the power of that
yeah i mean i really feel that you know
in
in business you need you need
accountability you need somebody to
reach out to i mean if you think about
any
any business it always had the board of
directors somebody above the ceo that
and then ultimately the shareholders
above that so you're always being
accountable so
you know being in business can be a
lonely place at the top so
um to have training to have mentorship
is really really important it's
something i've learned over the years
i didn't when i was young i didn't think
i needed help
i just went out there and thought i'm
just going to do this myself work really
hard
i'm savvy i know everything um i don't
need anybody's help
and i sort of push people away doug as
you've mentioned before who i work with
who's my
cousin he reached out to me many years
ago and said tony
you know do you want some help doing
this and i avoided
taking his calls to be honest and i just
didn't need
anybody and that was what was that was
that like an ego thing or
it sounds arrogant but it's more to do
with i just
didn't think i needed any help it wasn't
because i thought i knew
everything but it's just thought well
why would somebody else
who doesn't know exactly what i'm doing
be able to help me
right um but i was wrong on that
why were you wrong and do you regret do
you regret not taking help sooner
absolutely yeah talk to me about that
once again i said being a ceo of a
business is a very lonely place and you
know you
you're making decisions all the time the
art of business is making decisions
making quick decisions making decisions
which you know
based on you know what you're trying to
get out of it
and if you've got nobody to sound bored
off of uh
nobody to sort of share ideas with then
how do you know it's the right decision
yeah you know where just having a mentor
or having somebody to bounce those ideas
off of even if they don't know exactly
what your business is
by you by you um verbalizing it by you
talking to somebody
helps you sort of enforce that decision
in your head
whether it's righteousness the problem
is as well tony is if you haven't got an
official mentor
or a business coach or a trainer to to
follow and to guide you
i feel you'll end up getting advice from
people
anyway maybe your wife
or your kids or dave down the pub
and and they're going to give you
terrible advice yeah so you may as well
just get advice from the right people
absolutely absolutely because everyone
talks talks about their issues and
it's like who are the five people that
you're speaking with who are the five
people you're getting advice from your
bounce night is off
okay are those five people financially
free
if not if not maybe you need to find
some different people
um you know what have been your biggest
lessons mistakes because i know you've
had some real problems
your business oh my goodness you lost a
lot of money
a few years back yeah i mean what did
you learn from that
once again it was it was you know
by not reaching out at early stages of
my business
i didn't set my businesses up to fail
i never did i always thought success
would breed success would breed success
right so i had 30 years of of success
after
success and if we all know that success
is the worst
trainer yeah and because i didn't have
anybody to feedback and sort of to
to warn me about some of the pitfalls
that came ahead
when i um when i overextended myself a
few years back i paid for it
and paid for it big time yeah but
luckily i had my properties and so forth
which i could then bounce back on
and i was able to recover luckily but
if i'd reached out earlier and set my
business up
slightly differently i wouldn't have
been in that trouble in the first place
so yeah
i tell you what they say you can either
learn from your mistakes or you can
learn from somebody else's
absolutely or they say if you if you uh
pay for education
you won't have to pay as much for your
mistakes you're going to have less of
them right
um that's why i'm sorry that's why you
know
a few years back when i learned that i
decided to dedicate my life to trying to
help others
and how to stop them from making
mistakes
um i think you know coaches nowadays are
much
more looked upon as something which is a
good thing where
20 years 30 years ago it wasn't such a
thing but i think
now it is an accepted uh practice to to
employ mentors and spa
and coaches yeah and it's tax-deductible
yeah absolutely
claim it again claim it as a business
expense and you're also growing yourself
personally
um talk to me a little bit about it it's
interesting that you said that your
business
had serious problems right but
your passive income from your property
properties kind of bailed you out a
little bit
absolutely is that what you advise
people now do you do do you advise
people if
you're making money in business invest
it well absolutely
yeah i mean the business should be your
vehicle to
to financial freedom and passive income
right you know
i've always used my business to to to
you know
as that but i think you should do it
even more so
that yeah that the business should be
the vehicle so the business
business makes you money yeah then you
take that made money and you put it into
property absolutely
and then that property gives you passive
income which means if the business money
stops you've still got the passive
income which is what happened to you
yeah
i also believe in multiple streams of
income i think believe you know that
have
not just relying on any specific um you
know
avenue for income i think by having
different forms of income
in in property not just relying on one
strategy in property as well
having lots of multiple streams of
of income through property yeah you know
back in
pre-covert one of my properties was
mainly service accommodation uh which
hit
you know which hit of a cliff as you
know um and so you're a
if if all my property had been in that
situation then i'd be
struggling yeah but and you've lost a
lot of money
are you still a millionaire today yeah
good
and you're financially free today
absolutely but
you made some mistakes and you had to
you lost some millions as well
yeah um talk to me about why you
chose to spend so much time working with
me
well i found property exciting and
interesting
i've always have done and um and and
when i became when i went to crash
course i you know
it opened my eyes and ears and i i did
reach out
um i went on to simon zucci's courses i
went on to
other other mentors courses but they
weren't quite the same
um your your training is infectious
it's it it makes you you know get out
there and do things
but the training that that that you give
that samuel leeds gives
is much more of a doing type of training
where
it's not just textbook training where
you can learn about
how you how you make money through
property it's a case of i loved it when
on the crash course where you literally
said well i'm going to make a phone call
i'm going to phone an estate agent now
you got on the phone you phoned it in
front of
there was about about a thousand people
in the room at that stage and you
literally found
and just live went out there and did it
and and that
to me showed me that it was not just
textbook do this do this this is how you
do it
yeah um and that's that was that's the
big difference in the samuel leeds
training i i find
yeah that's really cool and i'm i'm so
glad that you
are not only doing creative things in
property now
what would have happened if you if you'd
have known the stuff that you know now
about property
30 years ago completely different world
for me
you you wouldn't just be a millionaire
you'd probably be a be on your way to a
billionaire you'd be
you'd be worth hundreds of millions
absolutely absolutely yeah but no
regrets
i mean i've you know i'm still very
young now and i'm still learning and i'm
still
and i'm and i've got a big future ahead
of me and i'm you know
and i've now decided that a big part of
my life is going to be property
yeah and also giving peop giving back
and i know you know i i know
that your heart is is to see other
people win
like you you spend hours on zoo
meetings talking to helping them you
don't have to do that
that's not necessarily you know in the
contracts or whatever
but what is it about other people's
success that gives you so much
satisfaction i just i it's i like
helping other people and i like i like
success and and
it doesn't have to be my success but but
to feed off other people's success is
really
you know it's fulfilling what's it like
what's it like being on the academy and
working with the academy students what's
the whole experience like
what's what's another great thing about
samuel leeds is it it
appeals to all people you know all
demographics and so forth so
it's not necessarily people who come
from privileged backgrounds
or you know who who make money to
property the samuel leads
does attract all sorts of people um from
all varying backgrounds
and i love dealing with them i love
working with them um
and helping them out at their certain
levels and
and just moving them along um and the
great thing about having people like you
involved and coaching the students is
that you'll be then giving me feedback
in terms of the business structure i
think we could do this more efficiently
or
i think we could add more value in this
way so it's just fabulous you know
you've
you've helped me personally you've
helped me in my business you've helped
the samuel leeds company
and i'm really grateful to that and i'm
so glad to see you
winning in property and and and doing
what you're doing so uh
thanks so much for coming on the show
what were you your final words of advice
if someone's saying look tony i want to
make a lot of money in business i want
to make a lot of money in property i
want to get started
like what were the first steps that you
would advise i would say education
you know education is is the main thing
you don't know what you don't know
uh and you need to know what is out
there what's available to you
and then you can decide what what's best
for you yeah um
but until you know that i didn't know
hmos existed i didn't know rent rent
existed
if i'd have known that back 20 years ago
or you know so forth
i'd be in a different position now so i
think
go out there and get as much knowledge
as you can about everything
and then follow a process that you know
it works
um have mentorship have coaching
uh reach out don't just stay in your
shell
yeah that's great what i've learned a
ton from you tony
i appreciate you as a mentor as a friend
and also in the property senses
as a student as well i don't feel
strange because you've been in property
way longer than i have
but thanks so much for coming on the
show guys i hope you enjoyed that i
think it's really good sometimes to just
get a real
rich not just financially but rich and
experienced
you know wise person where you can tap
into their knowledge so
i hope you appreciated the interview as
much as i i enjoyed actually
have been doing it firsthand do me a
massive favor
smash the like button drop a nice
comment below subscribe to the channel
and if you want to come down to the
property investors crash course
then i'll leave a i'll leave a link in
the description below and i hope you
enjoy that
every single week i have one of my
students sharing like tony's just shared
about how the samuel leads training has
changed their life and has helped them
make a lot of money
so you can watch the whole playlist
right here you can book onto the
property investors crash course up
right here and please do subscribe as
well right here
thanks so much for watching i'll see you
next time